Saddam Sayyaleh begins each day with a 6 AM walk around Cairo. It's the only 30 minutes of his day he gets to himself, before emails and meetings and the chaos of his enormously stressful job begins. His job? Right now, he's in charge of getting trucks filled with humanitarian aid into Gaza during the current war.
萨达姆·萨亚勒（Saddam Sayyaleh）每天早上6点都会在开罗散步。这是他一天中唯一属于自己的30分钟，在那之后，电子邮件、会议以及他那压力巨大的工作中产生的混乱就开始了。他的工作是什么？目前，他负责在当前的战争期间，将装满人道主义援助物资的卡车送入加沙。
He does this for a big American non-profit, called ANERA, that's sent aid into Gaza for decades. But since the war, every day, there are bottlenecks and logistical challenges, with all the different governments and agencies and militaries and aid groups involved. I talked to him at the end of a very long day of this, and-- I don't know, maybe this is a sign of his diplomatic skills-- he seemed so calm, so chill, that I couldn't not ask him about it.
他为一家名为ANERA的大型美国非营利组织工作，该组织几十年来一直向加沙运送援助物资。但战争爆发以来，由于涉及各个政府、机构、军队和援助组织，每天都存在瓶颈和后勤挑战。我在结束了非常漫长的一天工作后采访了他，而且——我不知道，也许这是他外交技巧的体现——他看起来如此冷静、如此淡定，我不得不向他请教原因。
Maybe that's just a facade, but--
也许那只是个伪装，但是——
It is. It is.
确实是。确实是。
It is a facade?
这是个伪装吗？
It is. (LAUGHING) I have to tell you, like, I learned the hard way to hold myself together. I think I'll break down after things ease up, but now, I can't. [LAUGHS] So I'm just keeping it-- I'm keeping it together.
是。（笑）我不得不告诉你，我是以惨痛的方式学会了保持镇定的。我想等事情平息后我会崩溃的，但现在，我不能。（笑）所以我只是保持着——我一直在硬撑。
I talked to Saddam twice, just before the recent ceasefire between Israel and Hamas and then during the ceasefire. I was interested in talking to him, because the stakes of any pause in fighting seem so high for aid workers like him. Before the ceasefire, so little humanitarian aid was actually making it into Gaza-- an average of only 55 trucks a day, according to the UN.
我在以色列和哈马斯最近的停火之前，以及停火期间，分别采访了萨达姆两次。我很有兴趣与他交谈，因为对于像他这样的援助工作者来说，战斗暂停带来的利害关系似乎非常重大。据联合国统计，停火前，实际进入加沙的人道主义援助物资非常少——平均每天只有55辆卡车。
Remember, at that point already, 1.7 million people in Gaza were displaced from their homes. Doctors had been operating without anesthesia. They didn't have painkillers and basic medicines. Food and water were in short supply.
请记住，当时加沙已经有170万人流离失所。医生在没有麻醉剂的情况下进行手术。他们没有止痛药和基本药物。食物和水严重短缺。
A pause in fighting would mean a chance to finally get stuff through, and I wanted to know how he was preparing and what he hoped would happen. And the answer was, about his preparations, his team in Gaza was going around, doing what they had basically been doing for weeks-- trying to figure out what the greatest needs were, like, for instance, in the schools and other buildings that are now the main shelters for over a million people in Gaza. These are incredibly overcrowded-- people sleeping on the ground everywhere.
战斗暂停意味着终于有机会将物资送进去，我想知道他如何准备，以及他希望发生什么。关于准备工作，他的回答是：他在加沙的团队一直在四处奔波，做他们几周来一直在做的事情——试图找出最大的需求是什么，例如，现在作为加沙100多万人主要避难所的学校和其他建筑。这些地方极其拥挤——到处都是睡在地上的人。
Like, just to give you a bit of an image, women are sleeping inside the rooms inside the school shelter, and the men are sleeping in the yard of the school. But also, a lot of families are on the streets, and it's winter. It's freezing.
给你一个画面，妇女们睡在学校避难所的房间里，而男人们睡在学校的院子里。此外，许多家庭流落街头，现在是冬天。天气非常冷。
And that's when our team in Gaza was like, we need tents, we need mattresses, we need blankets. And that's what I've been doing here. And immediately, we started procurement of tents in Egypt.
那时我们加沙的团队说，我们需要帐篷、床垫、毯子。这就是我在这里一直做的事情。我们立即开始在埃及采购帐篷。
Like, the first thing I did is I went to this sports shop at Decathlon, like the sports shop. And I told them, like, how many tents do you have? Because they're like-- they're for camping. They're already there. We can procure immediately.
我做的第一件事是去了一家迪卡侬运动商店。我问他们，你们有多少帐篷？因为它们是——它们是野营用的。它们就在那里。我们可以立即采购。
But they didn't buy these tents, because there was a problem with them. And to explain the problem, I should remind you that even before this war, for years now, Israel has controlled nearly everything that went in and out of Gaza. Gaza is surrounded by a giant fence.
但他们没有买这些帐篷，因为它们有问题。为了解释这个问题，我应该提醒你，即使在这次战争之前，多年来，以色列一直控制着几乎所有进出加沙的物资。加沙被一道巨大的栅栏包围着。
As part of that, Israel restricted specific certain metals and chemicals and fabrics from entering Gaza, because they said they didn't want them to fall into Hamas's hands and get turned into weapons against Israel or find some military use. There's an official list of restricted stuff.
作为其中的一部分，以色列限制特定的金属、化学品和织物进入加沙，因为他们说不想让这些东西落入哈马斯手中，被转化为针对以色列的武器或用于军事目的。有一份官方的限制物品清单。
Like with a tent, is the fabric-- there are certain type of fabrics that are not allowed. And then, we were like, OK, so it has materials that is not allowed. So we need to design our own tents.
比如帐篷，织物方面——有些类型的织物是不允许的。然后我们就想，好吧，它包含不允许的材料。所以我们需要自己设计帐篷。
And then, we needed to find a vendor who is willing to produce tents on certain specifications from scratch, immediately. Like, I mean, this vendor-- I met him on the same day. And then, I go back to him after four hours, and I tell him, I need 2,000 tents next week. And then, immediately, six workshops in Cairo-- they start producing these tents.
然后，我们需要找到一个愿意立即根据特定规格从零开始生产帐篷的供应商。我那天就见到了这位供应商。四小时后我回去找他，告诉他我下周需要2000顶帐篷。随即，开罗的六家作坊就开始生产这些帐篷了。
And those will be done what day?
那些帐篷什么日子能完工？
We're expecting the delivery next week.
我们预计下周交付。
Next week. So maybe in time for the ceasefire, maybe not. We were talking two days before the ceasefire started. But Saddam's organization, ANERA, had a whole bunch of other stuff that was ready to go and enter Gaza. And there's only one place to do that-- the Rafah crossing from Egypt into Gaza.
下周。所以可能赶得上停火，也可能赶不上。我们是在停火开始前两天谈话的。但萨达姆的组织ANERA还有一大堆其他准备好进入加沙的物资。而做到这一点只有一个地方——从埃及进入加沙的拉法口岸。
And Saddam said the trucks could be delayed there for days while Egyptian and Israeli officials each inspect the trucks to make sure that they are, in fact, filled with humanitarian aid. It is never clear how many of these trucks will make it through or if any will get through. Israel used to do these inspections at a big checkpoint, called Kerem Shalom, that was fully equipped to handle lots of inspections.
萨达姆说，卡车在那里可能会被延误数天，因为埃及和以色列的官员都要检查这些卡车，以确保它们确实装满了人道主义援助物资。目前还不清楚有多少辆卡车能通过，或者是否会有卡车能通过。以色列过去常在名为凯雷姆·沙洛姆（Kerem Shalom）的大型检查站进行这些检查，该检查站设备齐全，可以处理大量的检查工作。
But that checkpoint has been closed since the war started. The Rafah crossing just isn't set up for a high volume of trucks. And Saddam and other people trying to get humanitarian aid into Gaza understand all of that, but still do not understand the delays they see from day-to-day. It seems arbitrary to them.
但自战争开始以来，该检查站一直关闭。拉法口岸根本没有为大量的卡车做好准备。萨达姆和其他试图将人道主义援助送入加沙的人了解这一切，但仍然不理解他们每天看到的延误。对他们来说，这似乎是随意的。
Just yesterday, 79 trucks got in. But to give you a comparison, on a normal day before the war, it would have been 500 trucks a day. Like, it's shocking that only 79 trucks yesterday got in.
就在昨天，79辆卡车进去了。但做一个对比，战前正常的一天，会有500辆卡车。昨天只有79辆卡车进入，这令人震惊。
Yeah.
是的。
And some days, there were zero trucks going in.
而且有些日子，零辆卡车进入。
Saddam, like, why are so few trucks getting through?
萨达姆，为什么通过的卡车这么少？
So this is a question ANERA have been asking all along. We can't find the answer. We don't know the answer.
这是ANERA一直以来的疑问。我们找不到答案。我们不知道答案。
We reached out repeatedly to Israeli authorities to find out why more trucks aren't getting through the one checkpoint that they've allowed into Gaza. But we never got a reply. Once Saddam's trucks, full of aid, get into Gaza, they faced another problem before the ceasefire when we first talked. Other trucks inside Gaza were supposed to take the aid to where it needed to go inside Gaza, and those trucks needed fuel.
我们一再联系以色列当局，想弄清楚为什么更多的卡车不能通过他们允许进入加沙的唯一检查站。但我们从未得到回复。当萨达姆装满援助物资的卡车进入加沙后，当我们第一次谈话时，在停火前他们面临另一个问题。加沙境内的其他卡车原本应该将援助物资运送到需要的地方，而这些卡车需要燃料。
Fuel had been lacking for over two weeks. Like, there's no fuel inside Gaza. So ANERA have been very creative. Like, we've been using trolleys. We've been using livestock, donkeys, horses, to deliver the aid.
燃料已经短缺超过两周了。加沙境内没有燃料。所以ANERA一直在发挥创意。我们一直在使用手推车。我们一直在使用牲畜、驴子、马匹来运送援助物资。
Wait, wait, wait, you're using horses and donkeys to deliver international aid?
等等，等等，你们用马和驴来运送国际援助物资？
This is what is needed. Imagine there is no fuel. Imagine the size of Gaza.
这是必须的。想象一下没有燃料。想象一下加沙的大小。
So the ceasefire started the day after Thanksgiving, though, obviously, that is not how the participants viewed that particular date. The number of trucks crossing into Gaza with humanitarian aid roughly tripled. I talked to Saddam again on the seventh day of the ceasefire-- the last day. He told me his organization, ANERA, got more aid delivered in those seven days than it had in the two months of war before that.
停火是在感恩节后的第二天开始的，尽管很明显，参与者并不是那样看待那个特定日期的。越过边境进入加沙的人道主义援助卡车数量大约增加了两倍。我在停火的第七天——最后一天——再次与萨达姆交谈。他告诉我，他的组织ANERA在那七天里运送的援助物资比之前两个月的战争期间还要多。
That's actually what makes me really sad, is that we can get more and more aid in, but these inspections, delays-- as of November 29, at least 572 trucks were waiting on the road connecting the Egyptian and Israeli crossing, for the Israeli inspection of each truck takes hours.
这实际上让我非常难过，我们本可以运进越来越多的物资，但这些检查、延误——截至11月29日，至少有572辆卡车在连接埃及和以色列检查站的道路上等待，因为以色列对每辆车的检查都需要数小时。
Saddam, did your tents get across?
萨达姆，你的帐篷运过去了吗？
Not yet. Not yet.
还没有。还没有。
Production delays, he said. Quality issues. He's hoping they'll be ready next week. A day after that conversation, the ceasefire ended. Now, it's unclear exactly what it's going to be like next week and whether he's going to be able to get stuff through.
他说，生产延误。质量问题。他希望下周能准备好。在那次谈话后的一天，停火结束了。现在，下周会是什么样子，以及他是否能把物资送进去，还不清楚。
The first night the war resumed, my coworker, one of our producers Miki Meek and I, spoke with Juliette Touma, Director of Communications at UNRWA, UN Palestine Refugee Agency, which runs the shelters across Gaza that are housing now over a million people. That is, by the way, the UN agency that's had more of its staff killed than any UN mission in any conflict in the history of the United Nations. There's been 111 deaths in Gaza since October. Juliette Touma said that no trucks entered Gaza that first day, not one, after the pause in the war.
战争恢复的第一个晚上，我的同事，我们的制片人之一米基·米克（Miki Meek）和我，与联合国巴勒斯坦难民救济及工程处（UNRWA）的通讯主管朱丽叶·图玛（Juliette Touma）进行了交谈，该机构管理着加沙各地现在安置着超过100万人的避难所。顺便提一下，这是联合国历史上在任何冲突中员工死亡人数最多的联合国机构。自10月以来，加沙已有111人死亡。朱丽叶·图玛说，战争暂停后，第一天没有任何卡车进入加沙，一辆都没有。
So no humanitarian assistance, no fuel, no cooking gas, has come into Gaza today, and the bombardments and the airstrikes from the Israeli forces have continued across the Gaza Strip, including in the South.
所以今天没有任何人道主义援助，没有燃料，没有烹饪燃气进入加沙，以色列军队在整个加沙地带的轰炸和空袭仍在继续，包括南部。
The supplies that you were able to deliver during the pause-- do you guys have any sort of estimate for how long the supplies you have can last? Is it days? Is it weeks?
你们在暂停期间能够交付的物资——你们对这些物资能维持多久有什么估计吗？是几天？还是几周？
It's usually days. I don't think it's weeks.
通常是几天。我不认为有几周。
What are you hearing from staff who are in Gaza today?
你从今天在加沙的工作人员那里听到了什么？
Fear, concern. We are back to square zero, which is really, really not good. I mean, our colleagues-- many of them were displaced themselves. Many have lost loved ones, lost property, including homes.
恐惧，担忧。我们回到了原点，这真的非常非常不好。我的意思是，我们的同事——他们中的许多人自己也流离失所。许多人失去了亲人，失去了财产，包括家园。
Do you have any sense-- today, nothing got through. Do you have any sense of what the days are going to be like ahead of-- how much aid is going to get through?
你有没有感觉到——今天，什么都没送进去。你对未来几天有什么感觉——有多少援助能送进去？
I wish I knew. I wish I knew.
我希望我知道。我希望我知道。
So it's day by day.
所以是走一天看一天。
Mm-hmm. And well, sometimes, even hour by hour, I would say. There's so much uncertainty out there, so much.
嗯，有时候，我甚至会说是一小时一小时地看。外面有太多的不确定性，太多了。
And everything they've been able to get into Gaza is nowhere close to what's actually needed. The needs are so immense. Today, on our program, what happens when people desperately need help, need rescue. And the cavalry simply cannot rush in and save the day and fix everything.
而且他们能够运进加沙的一切，与实际需求相差甚远。需求太巨大了。今天，在我们的节目中，当人们急需帮助、急需救援时会发生什么。而骑兵部队根本无法冲进来拯救局面并解决一切问题。
When that happens, people get ingenious. People invent little solutions. People do that thing where you stop thinking about the big picture. Because the big picture is way too grim. And you just do the next task in front of you, and then the next one after that, and the next one after that, hoping it all helps, at least a little. It is a very particular kind of experience.
当这种情况发生时，人们变得足智多谋。人们发明小小的解决方案。人们会停止思考大局。因为大局太严峻了。你只是完成面前的下一个任务，然后是下一个，再下一个，希望这一切至少能有所帮助。这是一种非常特殊的体验。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Serious as a Heart Attack. So let's kick things off with this man, who's trying to do something that is so hard to do, and he knows very well that it is completely up to him. The cavalry is not coming, and he's figuring out how to hang on and make the best of things. He talked to Nancy Updike.
第一幕，如心脏病发作般严重。让我们从这个人开始，他试图做一件非常困难的事情，而且他非常清楚这完全取决于他自己。骑兵不会来，他正在想办法坚持下去并把事情做好。他与南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）交谈了。
It's just normal now in America for people to start a GoFundMe campaign if they have medical bills. The insane bills have become routine, so the insane DIY process of raising the money has also become routine. You'd be insane not to.
在美国，如果人们有医疗账单，发起GoFundMe活动现在很正常。疯狂的账单已经成为常态，所以筹款的疯狂DIY过程也成了常态。如果你不这样做，你就会疯掉。
But several weeks ago, I saw a new development in the field-- new to me, anyway. The CEO of a hospital had started a GoFundMe campaign to try and save the hospital. It's called Bucktail Medical Center, and the CEO is Tim Reeves. Tim says dire things in a calm voice. When we got on the phone and I asked him how quickly the hospital might close, he said--
但在几周前，我看到了该领域的一个新发展——无论如何对我来说是新的。一家医院的首席执行官发起了一项GoFundMe活动，试图挽救这家医院。它叫巴克泰尔医疗中心（Bucktail Medical Center），首席执行官是蒂姆·里夫斯（Tim Reeves）。蒂姆用冷静的声音说出可怕的事情。当我们通电话，我问他医院可能关闭的速度有多快时，他说——
I've put aside, in different accounts, enough money for one payroll. Trying to keep that two-week payroll in reserve, I hope, buys us two weeks. But I can't guarantee that.
我已经在不同的账户里留出了足够的钱来支付一笔工资。试图保留那两周的工资储备，我希望这能为我们争取两周时间。但我不能保证。
Bucktail Medical Center, this hospital, is a small single-story concrete building serving a bit more than 3,000 people in Renovo, Pennsylvania. It's the middle north-ish part of the state-- a lot of big forests and hunting land around there.
巴克泰尔医疗中心，这家医院，是一栋小型单层混凝土建筑，为宾夕法尼亚州雷诺沃（Renovo）的3000多名居民提供服务。它位于该州的中北部地区——周围有许多大森林和狩猎区。
Bucktail is the only hospital in the county. It's got a community clinic, 24-hour emergency room, ambulance service, 16 beds for acute care, and a small on-site nursing home. The next-closest hospital is 40 miles away. The next-closest emergency room is 34 miles away. And 34 miles is not an unbearably long ride, except for somebody having an emergency.
巴克泰尔是该县唯一的医院。它有一个社区诊所、24小时急诊室、救护车服务、16张急性护理床位和一个小型现场疗养院。最近的下一家医院在40英里外。最近的下一个急诊室在34英里外。34英里并不是一段无法忍受的距离，除非有人正在遭遇紧急情况。
We have a local guy. Our nursing staff know, when they see him pull into our parking lot, they call life flight, because they know that he's having a heart attack. The only time he shows up is when he's having a heart attack. He is not going to make it down the road.
我们有一个当地人。我们的护理人员知道，当他们看到他开进我们的停车场时，他们会呼叫生命飞行（life flight），因为他们知道他心脏病发作了。他唯一出现的时候就是他心脏病发作的时候。他到不了远处的医院。
We have a fair population of rattlesnakes here.
我们这里有相当多的响尾蛇。
Whoa, I didn't expect you to say that.
哇，我没想到你会这么说。
Yeah. So we had a person come in with a rattlesnake bite on his hand. It spanned almost the entire width of his hand, so it was a big snake.
是的。所以我们曾有一个人手部被响尾蛇咬伤。伤口几乎跨越了他整个手掌，所以那是一条大蛇。
Yikes.
天哪。
I always have two doses of anti-venom on hand, and a dose is four vials. So we got them the first four vials, put him in a helicopter, flew him out. He got, like, 28 more vials of anti-venom. If we were not here, that guy would be dead. He would not have survived the trip to Lockhaven.
我手头总是有两剂抗蛇毒素，一剂是四瓶。所以我们给他注射了前四瓶，把他放进直升机，把他送走了。他后来又得到了大约28瓶抗蛇毒素。如果我们不在这里，那个人就死定了。他无法在去洛克黑文（Lockhaven）的路上幸存下来。
When Tim takes a break from worrying about patients, he thinks about his staff-- 85 people who would lose jobs if the hospital closed. The hospital is one of the bigger employers in that half of the county. So how does a hospital get to the point where they're setting up a GoFundMe to stay in business?
当蒂姆从对病人的担忧中抽身时，他会想到他的员工——如果医院关闭，85人将失去工作。这家医院是该县那部分地区较大的雇主之一。那么，一家医院是如何走到需要设立GoFundMe来维持经营的地步的呢？
A few months ago, Bucktail was hit with a couple of big financial setbacks, one after another. There were some federal money that didn't come through that they'd been counting on, also some money the state says it overpaid them and now wants to take back. Those two hits put the hospital over $600,000 in the hole. Add to that all the things that can make it hard to keep any small rural hospital open-- small patient population and none of the specialties that can bring in a lot of money, like cardiac care, neurology.
几个月前，巴克泰尔接连遭受了两次重大的财务挫折。原本指望的一些联邦资金没有到位，还有一些州政府声称多付给他们的钱，现在想要收回。这两次打击让医院亏损了超过60万美元。再加上所有导致小型农村医院难以维持经营的因素——患者群体少，且没有能带来大量收入的专科，如心脏护理、神经内科。
Also, insurance doesn't cover Bucktail's costs. Most of the hospital's patients are on Medicare or Medicaid. The hospital breaks even with Medicare patients. Medicaid-- they lose money. But they also lose money on private insurance, because small hospitals don't have the leverage to negotiate decent reimbursement rates the way big hospitals do.
此外，保险不覆盖巴克泰尔的成本。医院的大部分病人都在享受医疗保险（Medicare）或医疗补助（Medicaid）。医院在医疗保险病人身上收支平衡。医疗补助——他们赔钱。但他们在私人保险上也赔钱，因为小型医院没有像大型医院那样协商体面报销率的杠杆。
Tim says Bucktail needs $1.5 million to make it through the fiscal year. He and the leadership team at Bucktail have drawn up a plan they believe can stabilize the hospital in the long term. But the short-term lack of money is clobbering them. And so, Tim is open to any idea about how to get money-- any idea, any amount of money.
蒂姆说，巴克泰尔需要150万美元才能度过这一财政年度。他和巴克泰尔的领导团队已经制定了一项他们认为可以长期稳定医院的计划。但短期的资金匮乏正在严重打击他们。因此，蒂姆对任何获取资金的想法持开放态度——任何想法，任何数额的钱。
The GoFundMe, which has raised about $16,000, was a board member's idea. The board is all volunteers who live in the community. The staff of the hospital is pitching in.
GoFundMe筹集了大约1.6万美元，是一位董事会成员的主意。董事会成员都是住在社区里的志愿者。医院的工作人员也在帮忙。
Our staff are looking for ways to do fundraisers. Right now, they're working in conjunction with one of the local fire departments to do a Bingo with $1,000 cash prize. They've gone out and they've gotten sponsors to put up the money for that prize as well as money to donate towards the facility. All that money will come to us.
我们的员工正在寻找筹款方式。目前，他们正在与当地的一家消防部门合作，举办一场奖金为1000美元现金的宾果游戏。他们已经出去寻找赞助商来提供这笔奖金，以及向设施捐款的资金。所有的钱都会汇给我们。
Our sewage authority has offered not to bill us for the next three months. The water company is not going to bill us for the next couple of quarters. We had a company that donated two new tires installed on our ambulance.
我们的污水处理部门提议在接下来的三个月内不向我们收费。水务公司在接下来的几个季度内不会向我们收费。我们有一家公司捐赠了两条安装在我们救护车上的新轮胎。
And these are because of calls that you're making or calls that other people on staff are making or a combination?
这些是因为你打的电话，还是员工打的电话，或者是两者结合？
It's definitely a combination.
绝对是结合。
Tim has an Excel spreadsheet that's a list of everything he and the leadership team are working on to try and save the hospital. Tim checks it every day, adds ideas, updates. It's 40 rows long and counting. I'm just going to read a few.
蒂姆有一个Excel电子表格，列出了他和领导团队为挽救医院所做的一切。蒂姆每天都会查看、增加想法、更新。它有40行长，而且还在增加。我只想读几行。
"Line 3, implement CT." The hospital bought a CAT scan machine, because patients have been going elsewhere to get CAT scans, and Bucktail wants to keep those patients. "Line 35, Oak Ridge Lumber." Years ago, someone donated a bunch of land to the hospital, the side of a mountain.
“第3行，实施CT检查”。医院购买了一台CT扫描机，因为病人为了做CT不得不去别的地方，巴克泰尔想留住这些病人。“第35行，橡树岭木材公司（Oak Ridge Lumber）”。多年前，有人向医院捐赠了一块土地，在山坡上。
A lumber company recently asked Tim if they could drive through that land to reach other land where they were going to cut down trees for lumber. And Tim said, hey, see if you want to buy any of our trees on our land for lumber. We will sell them to you. "Line 20, Electronic Sign." This is part of an effort to get more patients in the door.
一家木材公司最近问蒂姆，他们是否可以穿过那片土地到达他们准备砍伐树木用于木材的其他土地。蒂姆说，嘿，看看你们是否想买我们土地上的树木做木材。我们会卖给你们。“第20行，电子显示屏”。这是吸引更多病人到来的努力的一部分。
Where the hospital is located physically is kind of off the beaten path. If you drive through the middle of Renovo, unless you know where the hospital's at, you won't see it.
医院所处的物理位置有点偏僻。如果你开车穿过雷诺沃市中心，除非你知道医院在哪里，否则你不会看到它。
The sign is not for locals. The hospital's been in that location for decades. It's for out-of-towners.
这个标志不是给当地人看的。医院在那个位置已经几十年了。它是给外地人看的。
We have thousands of camps, private camps, up here. People will come in for hunting season or fishing season or for summer vacations or-- to get away for a weekend or whatever it is. So the electronic sign, we hope, is a way that we can start to convey some of that information to people that are driving through the middle of town.
我们这里有成千上万的营地，私人营地。人们会来这里过狩猎季节或钓鱼季节，或者度假，或者——过周末什么的。所以电子显示屏，我们希望，是一种我们可以开始向驾车经过市中心的人传达一些信息的方式。
An electronic sign, Bingo, donated tires, lumber, a GoFundMe. I feel like this is one of those local TV stories about a plucky person who is trying to solve, through sheer gumption, a problem they shouldn't even have. Like, look, this hero is walking eight miles each way to a job, because there's no public transportation where he lives. How great is this guy?
电子显示屏、宾果游戏、捐赠的轮胎、木材、GoFundMe。我觉得这是一个关于勇敢的人试图通过纯粹的毅力解决他们本不该有的问题的当地电视故事。就像，看，这个英雄为了工作每天步行8英里，因为他住的地方没有公共交通。这个人有多棒？
The biggest chunk of money Tim's gotten so far is an advance on a payment the hospital is supposed to get next year-- $189,000-- a lot of money, unless you're trying to run a hospital.
蒂姆到目前为止获得的最大一笔资金是医院本应在明年获得的付款预付款——18.9万美元——如果你在经营一家医院，这笔钱很多，除非你在经营一家医院。
Sleep is difficult. There are many, many days when I get home and I'm just emotionally exhausted.
睡眠很困难。有很多很多天，我回家时只是在情感上精疲力竭。
Are you getting any sleep?
你有睡觉吗？
Some.
有一点。
The day before Thanksgiving, I got Tim's weekly email update that he sends out to a bunch of people. It said, quote, "We had a meeting with the staff this afternoon at 3 o'clock. The meeting today was more difficult than meetings we've had in the past.
感恩节前一天，我收到了蒂姆发给一群人的每周电子邮件更新。上面写着，引用，“我们今天下午3点与员工开了会。今天的会议比我们过去的会议更困难。”
Likewise, this is the most difficult update I have provided. Until today, I've been able to report that the next payroll is covered. I could not provide that assurance today."
同样，这是我提供过的最困难的更新。直到今天，我还能报告下一份工资单已经有了着落。我今天无法提供这种保证。”
He said he had no idea how they could continue providing services past December 1. He said, quote, "We are out of time without some temporary support." I thought about an earlier conversation I'd had with Tim. We were on the phone, and I was looking over a copy of a letter he'd sent to elected officials, laying out what's happening at Bucktail. One line stopped me short.
他说他不知道他们在12月1日之后如何继续提供服务。他说，引用，“如果没有一些临时支持，我们已经没有时间了。”我回想起了之前与蒂姆的一次谈话。我们在电话里，我正在看他发给民选官员的一封信的复印件，详细说明了巴克泰尔发生的事情。一行字让我停住了。
I just got to the line where you say, "I have personally provided the facility with an interest-free loan." Oh, my goodness, Tim.
我刚才读到你写的那一行，“我个人为该机构提供了无息贷款”。噢，天哪，蒂姆。
The only people that know are the people in the business office who had to process it and the board of directors.
唯一知道的人是必须处理它的商务办公室人员和董事会。
Does your wife know?
你妻子知道吗？
Yep.
是的。
Is she worried about that?
她对此感到担心吗？
Is she worried about it? Yes. Am I worried about it? Yeah. But it was necessary to get over a hurdle.
她担心吗？是的。我担心吗？是的。但这对于跨越障碍是必要的。
Can I ask how much?
我能问问是多少钱吗？
$50,000.
5万美元。
Oh, my goodness. Oh, my goodness. I mean, if the hospital goes under, would you get that back?
噢，天哪。噢，天哪。我的意思是，如果医院倒闭了，你能拿回那笔钱吗？
No.
不能。
Oh, my god, Tim.
噢，天哪，蒂姆。
I want to be optimistic that we're going to find a solution. I asked myself a little while ago, if I had to make that decision again, would I make the same decision? And the answer is, yes.
我想保持乐观，认为我们会找到解决办法。我刚才问自己，如果我必须再次做出那个决定，我还会做出同样的决定吗？答案是，是的。
To loan the money?
贷款吗？
Yep.
是的。
This week, payroll is due. At the last minute, the hospital managed to expedite an insurance reimbursement, and they will be able to pay the staff after all. What that means for Tim is, he's got another two-week increment to work on Plan A, fighting to keep the hospital open. But he's had to add a line to the spreadsheet for Plan B. It's line 48, "Closure."
这周，工资到期了。在最后一刻，医院设法加快了保险报销，他们终究能够支付员工工资。对蒂姆来说，这意味着他又有两周的时间来执行A计划，努力保持医院开放。但他不得不在电子表格中为B计划增加一行。这是第48行，“关闭”。
Nancy Updike is a senior editor on our program. Coming up-- OK, sure, there are places where people hope that the federal government is going to swoop in with millions of dollars and fix everything. But what if you are the federal government? What do you hope for then? Answers from some actual federal employees-- that's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
南希·厄普代克是我们节目的高级编辑。接下来——好吧，当然，有些地方的人希望联邦政府能带着数百万美元冲进来解决一切问题。但如果你自己就是联邦政府呢？那时候你希望什么？来自一些真正的联邦雇员的答案——那是芝加哥公共广播电台节目继续后的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our show, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- "The Cavalry Is Not Coming"-- stories about all the things you do-- some of them clever, some of them angry-- when you realize that no one is going to show up to rescue you. We have arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, Give Me Your Tired, Your Poor, Your Huddled Masses-- Or Don't.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，为您带来关于该主题的各种不同的故事。今天的节目——“骑兵部队不会来”——关于当你意识到没有人会来救你时，你所做的所有事情的故事——其中一些很聪明，一些很愤怒。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，把你们疲惫、贫穷、蜷缩的群众交给我——或者不交给我。
So if you want to immigrate to the United States from another country, OK, there are a bunch of ways to do that. But the big one for people wanting to cross from the southern border into the United States is the asylum program. For most people, that is the only legal pathway if they want to stay here.
所以，如果你想从另一个国家移民到美国，好吧，有很多方法可以做到这一点。但对于想从南部边境越境进入美国的人来说，大的一个途径是庇护计划。对于大多数人来说，如果他们想留在这里，那是唯一合法的途径。
Asylum means not just coming here to get a better job or have a better life in some way. They have to show that they are running from some kind of danger or persecution back home. This all comes out of post-World War II idealism-- this law, this idea that the United States can and should give refuge to people fleeing oppression.
庇护不仅仅是为了来这里找更好的工作或以某种方式过上更好的生活。他们必须证明他们是在逃离家乡的某种危险或迫害。这一切都源于二战后的理想主义——这项法律，这种认为美国能够并且应该为逃离压迫的人们提供庇护的想法。
Under President Trump, as you probably remember, it became a lot harder to get asylum. We did a story back then during his administration about the people who do the first screenings of asylum applicants at the United States Citizenship and Immigration Services, USCIS. These people are asylum officers.
在特朗普总统领导下，正如你可能记得的，获得庇护变得困难得多。那时我们做了一个关于在美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）进行庇护申请人初步筛查的人员的故事。这些人是庇护官。
And back then, they told us that from their point of view, President Trump was keeping out all kinds of people who should have been allowed into the country. And they said they yearned for some cavalry to ride in, some new president, to change things, save the day. Now, of course, they have a new president in Joe Biden. And things have not gone the way these officials hoped for.
那时，他们告诉我们，从他们的角度来看，特朗普总统把各种本应获准入境的人拒之门外。他们说他们渴望有骑兵来拯救局面，有位新总统来改变现状。现在，当然，他们有了乔·拜登这位新总统。事情并没有像这些官员希望的那样发展。
One of our producers, Nadia Reiman, talked to a whole different bunch of USCIS officials recently-- these are people who work in the asylum and refugee branches-- and got this window into the whole immigration system that you don't usually get. Here's Nadia.
我们的制片人之一，纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman），最近与一群完全不同的美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）官员进行了交谈——这些人是在庇护和难民部门工作的人——并获得了你通常无法了解的整个移民系统的窗口。这是纳迪亚的故事。
Let me start the story the way we have to start so many asylum stories-- by explaining what the hell the people who work in these jobs actually do. The ones I talked to were all asylum officers at some point, and here's what that looks like. They sit in an office, on the phone for hours with asylum seekers and an interpreter on the line.
让我以我们不得不开始如此多庇护故事的方式来开始这个故事——通过解释这些工作岗位上的人到底在做什么。我采访的人都曾是庇护官，情况是这样的。他们坐在办公室里，在电话上与庇护寻求者和翻译谈话几个小时。
They're asking questions, hearing brutal stories from people who recently crossed the border about what they're fleeing-- Venezuelan political activists escaping the government, Cameroonians fleeing violence, Salvadoran families escaping gangs. The officers have to determine whether the migrants they're talking to could get legal protection here under US law and whether they could face harm, or even death, if they got sent back to their home country.
他们提出问题，听到刚过边境的人讲述他们正在逃离什么——逃离政府的委内瑞拉政治活动家，逃离暴力的喀麦隆人，逃离帮派的萨尔瓦多家庭。官员们必须确定他们交谈的移民是否可以在美国法律下在这里获得法律保护，以及如果他们被遣返回国，是否会面临伤害，甚至是死亡。
It's not for the faint of heart, but it is more for the bleeding-heart crowd than the enforcement crowd. These aren't the tough-guy cops you often find in the border patrol. Lots of them worked for the Peace Corps, lots of people with an immigration law background or human rights. They understand that their decisions in these cases can dictate whether someone lives or dies, and every one of them I've ever talked to feels the weight of that. It's a moral duty to them, not just a 9-to-5.
这不适合胆小的人，但它更吸引充满同情心的人，而不是执法人员。这些人不是你在边境巡逻队中经常发现的强硬警察。他们中的许多人为和平队工作过，许多人有移民法或人权背景。他们明白，他们在这些案件中的决定可以决定某人的生死，我采访过的每一个人都感到了那种重量。对他们来说，这是一种道义责任，而不仅仅是朝九晚五的工作。
After four years of President Trump dismantling the asylum and refugee programs and calling their work a con, they felt desperate for a change. And then, in the months before the 2020 election, in a random press event, Joe Biden caught their ear for the first time because of the way he started talking about asylum seekers.
在特朗普总统拆除庇护和难民计划并将他们的工作称为骗局四年后，他们对变革感到绝望。然后，在2020年选举前的几个月里，在一次随机的媒体活动中，乔·拜登第一次引起了他们的注意，因为他开始谈论庇护寻求者的方式。
We're going to restore our moral standing in the world and our historic role as a safe haven for refugees and asylum seekers and those fleeing violence and persecution. My Lord, we've never-- we've never made asylum seekers stay-- seek asylum outside the United States of America.
我们将恢复我们在世界上的道德地位，以及我们作为难民、庇护寻求者和逃离暴力与迫害者的安全避风港的历史作用。天哪，我们从来没有——我们从来没有让庇护寻求者留在——在美国境外寻求庇护。
Making asylum seekers wait outside the US-- that's a Trump policy that these USCIS workers hated. To them, this was a signal, like Biden was nodding at them, paying attention to their corner of the sandbox. When Joe Biden won, their hopes were modest. They knew immigration was never one of his big issues. But hey, at least he'd set things back on a better course.
让庇护寻求者在美国境外等待——那是特朗普的一项政策，这些美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）工作人员非常讨厌。对他们来说，这是一个信号，就像拜登在向他们点头，关注沙盒的那个角落。当乔·拜登获胜时，他们的期望很低。他们知道移民从来不是他的重大议题之一。但嘿，至少他会把事情带回更好的轨道。
Well, at least, we'll go back to what we had in the Obama administration. We're going to return to normalcy. We're going to return to an immigration system that's bad in many ways but we're not going to go out of our way to hurt people.
好吧，至少，我们会回到我们在奥巴马政府时期所拥有的。我们将恢复正常。我们将回到一个在许多方面都很糟糕的移民系统，但我们不会特意去伤害人。
That's an asylum officer I'm going to call Mark-- not his real name, also not his real voice. You'll hear voice actors instead of the immigration officials themselves, imitating their voices and inflections as closely as possible. Because these folks are not supposed to talk to the press. They could get fired.
这是一位我称之为马克（Mark）的庇护官——不是他的真名，也不是他的真实声音。你会听到配音演员而不是移民官员本人，尽可能接近地模仿他们的声音和语调。因为这些人不应该与媒体交谈。他们可能会被解雇。
That's also why I can't tell you a lot about Mark or any of the others you'll hear. What I can say is that Mark is precise and overall kind of a curmudgeon. Once Biden won, Mark says he and his colleagues expected that pretty early on, he'd end something called Title 42.
这也是我不能告诉你太多关于马克或你听到的其他任何人的原因。我能说的是，马克一丝不苟，总的来说有点愤世嫉俗。拜登获胜后，马克说他和他的同事们很早就预料到他会结束一项叫做“第42条”（Title 42）的政策。
Title 42 was a public health order that had basically closed the southern border to prevent the spread of COVID. It allowed US border officers to expel migrants back into Mexico with no legal formalities, no questions asked, hours after they were caught. The Trump administration put it in place when the pandemic hit.
“第42条”是一项公共卫生令，基本上关闭了南部边境以防止COVID传播。它允许美国边境官员在移民被抓获数小时后，不经过法律程序，不询问任何问题，就将他们驱逐回墨西哥。特朗普政府在疫情爆发时实施了这项政策。
Asylum and refugee officers thought this was illegal, because it prevented people from even being able to ask for asylum. Mark and his coworkers were like, easy. Trump activated it. Biden could just deactivate it.
庇护和难民官员认为这是非法的，因为它甚至阻止了人们请求庇护的能力。马克和他的同事们当时想，这很容易。特朗普激活了它。拜登可以直接停用它。
The person I talked to who was the most optimistic about the whole thing is a USCIS official I'm going to call George. He's been at the agency through many administrations. He watches the first weeks of the Biden administration roll by-- nothing. But George wasn't bothered.
我采访的对整件事最乐观的人是一位美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）官员，我称他为乔治（George）。他历经多届政府都在该机构工作。他看着拜登政府的前几周过去——什么都没有发生。但乔治并不介意。
I actually-- I ran into a co-worker, and we were like, oh, you know, these advocates are all mad that we haven't ended Title 42 yet. And I'm like, we at least need a few weeks to plan it out, right? Like, I understand they can't do it immediately, but they'll do it soon enough. It will be fine. So.
我实际上——我遇到了一位同事，我们就像，哦，你知道，这些倡导者都对我们还没有结束“第42条”感到愤怒。而我就像，我们至少需要几周时间来规划，对吧？我的意思是，我明白他们不能立即做到，但他们很快就会做到。没事的。所以。
So how did it go?
那结果怎么样？
Not well, Nadia Reiman. Not well. [LAUGHS] Yeah. I would say I started to get-- started to get very concerned and very suspicious around the first time they had the opportunity to end Title 42, and they decided to extend it.
不太好，纳迪亚·雷曼。不太好。（笑）是的。我想说我开始变得——在他们第一次有机会结束“第42条”而决定延长它时，我开始变得非常担心和怀疑。
This was back in 2021, around August. Back then, we had a huge wave of people showing up at the border. Lots of them thought, OK, Trump's gone. Biden sounds more friendly. Maybe now, I have a chance to get in.
那是2021年，大约8月份。那时，我们有大量的人涌向边境。他们中的许多人认为，好吧，特朗普走了。拜登听起来更友好。也许现在，我有机会进去了。
By keeping Title 42, President Biden could keep them from crossing into the US. And every USCIS official I talked to heard the same story George did about why the administration made that choice.
通过保留“第42条”，拜登总统可以阻止他们进入美国。我采访的每一位美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）官员都听到了与乔治相同的关于政府为何做出该选择的说法。
Political operators at the White House became convinced that it was bad for the president for the TV to show what would be characterized as chaos at the border.
白宫的政治操盘手开始相信，如果电视上展示被定性为边境混乱的画面，这对总统不利。
I asked the White House if this is why the president kept Title 42 going, and not public health concerns. They said it was the CDC's call, not the president's. The USCIS workers I talked to didn't buy this. In fact, George remembers how the Biden administration doubled down on this argument when the ACLU sued the government over Title 42.
我问白宫，这就是总统保留“第42条”的原因吗，而不是出于公共卫生担忧。他们说这是疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）的决定，不是总统的。我交谈过的美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）工作人员不相信这一点。事实上，乔治记得当美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）因“第42条”起诉政府时，拜登政府是如何加倍重申这一论点的。
And then, you had them making these absurd public statements that were parroting the things the Trump administration was saying about Title 42, which Democrats laughed at and dismissed when Trump was in office, but when they-- you know, oh, we have nothing to do with this. This is a CDC order. This is related to public health, not immigration, you know.
然后，你看到他们发表了这些荒谬的公开声明，鹦鹉学舌般地重复特朗普政府关于“第42条”的说法，民主党人在特朗普执政时对此嗤之以鼻，但当他们——你知道，哦，我们对此无能为力。这是疾病控制与预防中心的命令。这与公共卫生有关，而不是移民，你知道的。
Keeping Title 42 going as long as they did was a "what the hell" moment for the USCIS workers, a turning point. Seeing all these people trying to seek asylum stuck outside our borders because of Title 42 made these workers feel angry and lonely, like they were the only witnesses to a bridge collapsing while everyone else looked the other way.
将“第42条”维持这么久，对美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）的工作人员来说是一个“搞什么鬼”的时刻，一个转折点。看到所有这些试图寻求庇护的人因为“第42条”而滞留在国界外，使这些工作人员感到愤怒和孤独，就像他们是桥梁坍塌的唯一目击者，而其他人却视而不见。
This next person, I'll call Lisa. She works in refugee services. She was also the only official who didn't swear during her interview.
下一个人，我称她为丽莎（Lisa）。她在难民服务部门工作。她也是采访中唯一没有说脏话的官员。
I mean, I stopped talking about it with my friends and family, to be honest.
我的意思是，老实说，我不再和朋友和家人谈论它了。
You did?
你不再谈了？
Yeah. Because all it does is work-- all it would do is work me up into a frenzy of frustration. And they can only listen to it for so much, especially when they all, too, are under this illusion that, oh, but isn't it so much better? Oh, we understand and remember how horrible it was under the Trump administration. But isn't it so much better?
是的。因为我所做的就是——所有它会做的事情就是让我陷入挫折的狂热中。他们只能听这么多，特别是当他们也都处于这种错觉中时，哦，但不是好多了吗？哦，我们理解并记得在特朗普政府下有多糟糕。但不是好多了吗？
And you want to say, like, yeah, it's better. We're not under full-level destruction attack, but also, promises were made, and they're not happening, and people are still living in refugee camps on the southern side of the border, and no one is doing anything to help them. [SIGHS] You just-- you feel like you can't talk to the regular world about it anymore.
你想说，就像，是的，好多了。我们没有受到全面毁灭性的攻击，但同时，承诺已经做出，而它们没有实现，人们仍然住在边境南侧的难民营里，没有人做任何事情来帮助他们。（叹气）你只是——你觉得你再也不能和普通世界谈论它了。
In the end, it took President Biden over a year to try to end Title 42. And when he did it, Texas sued and stopped him. Title 42 remained in place until May of this year. It was there through half of President Biden's term.
最终，拜登总统花了超过一年的时间试图结束“第42条”。当他这样做时，德克萨斯州起诉并阻止了他。“第42条”一直持续到今年5月。它在拜登总统任期的一半时间里都在那里。
So in those first two years of the Biden administration, lots of people were being turned away at the border. But at the same time, incredibly, lots of other people were being allowed in-- mostly Venezuelans and Cubans, Nicaraguans, some Haitians. More than a million migrants were allowed into the US in two years.
所以在拜登政府的前两年，许多人在边境被拒之门外。但与此同时，令人难以置信的是，许多其他人被允许进入——主要是委内瑞拉人和古巴人、尼加拉瓜人、一些海地人。在两年内，超过一百万移民被允许进入美国。
So why did this happen? Take Venezuela, for example. The US didn't have good diplomatic relationships with Venezuela, so we couldn't fly Venezuelans back to their country when they showed up at the border. And Mexico didn't want them waiting on their side, which meant the Biden administration was stuck.
那为什么会这样？以委内瑞拉为例。美国与委内瑞拉没有良好的外交关系，所以当委内瑞拉人出现在边境时，我们无法用飞机把他们遣返回国。而墨西哥也不想让他们在那一边等待，这意味着拜登政府陷入了困境。
They had to figure out what to do. And the solution they came up with for Venezuela and all these countries was temporary. All the immigrants that came in, the more than a million-- most are here on temporary permits, officially allowed to stay for a while until things in their home countries cool down.
他们不得不弄清楚该怎么办。他们为委内瑞拉和所有这些国家提出的解决方案是临时的。所有进来的移民，那一百多万——大多数都持有临时许可证，正式允许停留一段时间，直到他们祖国的情况平息下来。
At first, this was kind of an ad-hoc thing the Biden administration did, a bit under the radar, just to relieve pressure at the border. There had been dangerous overcrowding at border patrol stations. Later, this became a more official program they proudly point to as proof that they stand up for humanitarian ideals.
起初，这只是拜登政府做的一种临时举措，有点不透明，只是为了缓解边境的压力。边境巡逻站曾发生危险的拥挤。后来，这变成了一个更正式的计划，他们自豪地指出这是他们坚持人道主义理想的证明。
But one of the officials I talked to pointed out temporary status can funnel a lot of people away from getting asylum, which is permanent. Whatever their intentions, by January of this year, the Biden administration had made two main parallel tracks for immigrants. Tons of people coming in with temporary statuses, tons of others kept out by Title 42.
但我交谈过的一位官员指出，临时身份可以引流许多人不去获得永久的庇护。无论他们的意图如何，到今年1月，拜登政府已经为移民建立了两个主要的平行轨道。大量的人带着临时身份进来，大量其他人被“第42条”挡在外面。
And that's when the CDC announced the public health crisis was officially over. Title 42 had to end, which is great news for these USCIS workers, right? Just what they've been waiting for.
那时，疾病控制与预防中心宣布公共卫生危机正式结束。“第42条”必须结束，这对这些美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）工作人员来说是个好消息，对吧？正是他们一直在等待的。
As they sit in their offices, they wonder what the plan is, how they're supposed to handle what may be large numbers of new asylum applicants. The last day of Title 42 keeps looming closer and closer, and these workers are hearing nothing. Then, some rumblings.
当他们坐在办公室里时，他们想知道计划是什么，他们应该如何处理可能大量的新的庇护申请人。“第42条”的最后一天越来越近，而这些工作人员什么都没听到。然后，一些传闻出现了。
And then, when I heard that they were going to drop a new rule, I was like, of course they are.
然后，当我听说他们要发布一项新规则时，我就想，当然会这样。
The new rules spelled out, for the first time, how the Biden administration wanted to run asylum at the southern border for now-- an original policy of their own to handle the crowds of people they expected would cross the border once Title 42 ended. The rule is called CLP, which stands for Circumvention of Lawful Pathways.
新规则首次阐明了拜登政府目前希望如何在南部边境运行庇护政策——他们自己的一项原创政策，旨在处理他们预期在“第42条”结束后会越境的大量人群。该规则被称为CLP，即“规避合法途径”（Circumvention of Lawful Pathways）。
The rule was not just any rule. It's like a Swiss Army knife, many different rules all rolled into one. But the part that jumped out to these USCIS workers the most is that under the rule, in order to even apply for asylum, you have to show that you already applied for asylum and got denied in at least one country you've passed through before getting to the US.
这项规则不仅仅是任何规则。它就像一把瑞士军刀，许多不同的规则合而为一。但最让这些美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）工作人员震惊的部分是，根据该规则，为了能够申请庇护，你必须证明你在到达美国之前已经至少在一个你经过的国家申请过庇护并被拒绝。
So if you came up from South America, you went through Panama, then Costa Rica, then Nicaragua, then Honduras, then El Salvador, then Guatemala, then Mexico, you would have to apply for asylum and be denied in at least one of those. If you don't have proof of this, you are not eligible for asylum here. Doesn't matter what you're fleeing in your home country.
所以，如果你从南美洲上来，你穿过巴拿马，然后是哥斯达黎加，然后是尼加拉瓜，然后是洪都拉斯，然后是萨尔瓦多，然后是危地马拉，然后是墨西哥，你必须至少在其中一个国家申请庇护并被拒绝。如果你没有这方面的证明，你在这里就没有资格获得庇护。无论你在家乡逃离什么，都不重要。
Your government could be actively trying to kill you and your family because you're a political activist. Clear-cut asylum claim-- not relevant anymore. You basically won't get asylum in the US, because these other countries didn't reject you first.
你的政府可能因为你是政治活动家而积极试图杀害你和你的家人。明确的庇护主张——不再相关了。你基本上不会在美国获得庇护，因为这些其他国家没有先拒绝你。
The USCIS workers I talked to were floored by this. They were like, whoa, that's basically something President Trump tried to put in place, but the court struck it down quickly, said it was illegal. And now, here was president Biden bringing it back-- or something that looked a lot like it. It was mind-blowing.
我采访的美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）工作人员对此感到震惊。他们就像，哇，那基本上是特朗普总统试图实施的东西，但法院迅速将其驳回，称其为非法。现在，拜登总统又把它带回来了——或者看起来非常像的东西。这太令人难以置信了。
It's the same. Yeah. Yeah, they tweaked it around the corners, and the people who had to work on writing that rule-- I mean, jeez. Like, I can't even imagine, to be the one who was told, yeah, we did that rule, and we know that it's illegal, but let's try this one. [CHUCKLES]
是一样的。是的。是的，他们在边缘做了微调，那些不得不致力于撰写该规则的人——我的意思是，天哪。就像，我甚至无法想象，成为那个被告知，是的，我们制定了那项规则，我们知道它是非法的，但让我们试试这一项的人。（笑）
Now, this is pretty clearly unlawful.
现在，这显然是不合法的。
At this point, George takes out a thick book, very official-looking. It's a bound copy of the Immigration and Nationality Act he just happened to have around the house, you know, as one does.
此时，乔治拿出了一本厚书，看起来非常官方。这是他在家里偶然发现的一本装订版的《移民与国籍法》，你知道，就像人们常有的那样。
I mean, let's just read the asylum statute, right? "Any alien who is physically present in the United States or who arrives in the United States, whether or not--"
我的意思是，让我们读读庇护法，好吗？“任何实际身处美国或抵达美国的外国人，无论其是否——”
Basically, this says anyone who arrives here in any way, legally or illegally, can apply for asylum.
基本上，这说的是任何以任何方式抵达这里的人，无论合法或非法，都可以申请庇护。
And so what Circumvention of Lawful Pathways says is, yeah, sure, you can-- you can apply, but we're going to say you're ineligible.
所以“规避合法途径”说的是，是的，当然，你可以——你可以申请，但我们要说你没有资格。
I reached out to one of the administration officials who oversees the CLP-- Assistant Secretary for Immigration and Border Policy, Blas Nunez-Neto. I asked him how CLP is different from President Trump's asylum ban, which had been ruled illegal.
我联系了监督CLP的政府官员之一——负责移民和边境政策的助理部长布拉斯·努涅斯-内托（Blas Nunez-Neto）。我问他CLP与特朗普总统的庇护禁令有何不同，后者已被裁定为非法。
The Trump administration approach to this was to impose a categorical ban on asylum at the land border.
特朗普政府的做法是在陆地边境对庇护实施绝对禁令。
He's saying their ban was categorical. It applied to everyone, no exceptions.
他说他们的禁令是绝对的。它适用于所有人，没有任何例外。
So we're not denying asylum categorically to anybody at the land border, and that's just a fact and something that is important for your audience to understand. What we have done is, essentially, create what we call a rebuttable presumption. And that's important, because it is, in fact, rebuttable, and that means that people who cross between the ports of entry and have a compelling reason why they needed to do that can rebut the presumption, and we're seeing many people do that in practice.
所以我们并没有在陆地边境绝对地拒绝任何人的庇护，这是一个事实，对于你们的受众来说，理解这一点很重要。我们所做的是，本质上，创造了我们所说的“可反驳推定”。这很重要，因为它是事实上的可反驳的，这意味着那些在入境口岸之间越境并且有令人信服的理由必须这样做的人可以反驳这一推定，我们看到许多人在实践中这样做。
"A rebuttable presumption"-- that means CLP starts off assuming you are ineligible for asylum. But don't worry, you can prove it wrong. You can rebut, like, immediately, right there on the spot, when you talk to an asylum officer. Prove it wrong, and then, poof, it's gone. Doesn't apply to you anymore.
“可反驳推定”——这意味着CLP开始时假设你没有资格获得庇护。但别担心，你可以证明它是错的。你可以反驳，就像你和庇护官交谈时，当场那样。证明它是错的，然后，砰，它就消失了。它不再适用于你了。
There's a list of ways to rebut the rule. First, it doesn't apply to unaccompanied minors or if you're sick and you need medical care. That's an exception. Or if you're being trafficked-- another thing that negates the rule. Or if you're in imminent danger, if someone is actively trying to kill you there at the border-- that's an exception for, quote, "extreme and imminent threat to life or safety," which all sounds reasonable enough.
有一份反驳规则的方法清单。首先，它不适用于无人陪伴的未成年人，或者如果你生病了需要医疗护理。这是一个例外。或者如果你被贩卖——另一件否定该规则的事情。或者如果你处于迫在眉睫的危险中，如果有人在边境积极试图杀害你——这是对，引用，“对生命或安全的极端和迫在眉睫的威胁”的例外，这听起来都足够合理。
But the officers I spoke with and people I talked to who work with migrants along the border-- they all say it's really, really, ridiculously difficult to get one of these exceptions or rebuttals. An attorney I talked to from the Texas Civil Rights Project says she's known of cases where the medical emergency rebuttal is so hard to get, it takes so long, that migrants have gotten sicker and sicker and have died waiting for it. Mark says that when he's interviewing asylum seekers and trying to apply these CLP rules, he doesn't like where it leads him and who he ends up rejecting.
但我交谈过的官员以及我交谈过的在边境与移民一起工作的人——他们都说获得这些例外或反驳真的、真的非常荒谬地困难。我从德克萨斯民权项目（Texas Civil Rights Project）采访的一位律师说，她知道一些案例，其中医疗紧急情况的反驳太难获得，时间太长，以至于移民在等待时病情越来越重并已经死亡。马克说，当他在面试庇护寻求者并试图应用这些CLP规则时，他不喜欢这导致的结果，以及他最终拒绝的人。
The consequences of getting things wrong-- the stakes are extremely high. When you get it wrong, people will die. And it's not hyperbole. That's not being hysterical. That is a fact.
出错的后果——利害关系极其重大。当你犯错时，人们会死亡。这不是夸张。那不是歇斯底里。那是一个事实。
It is life-or-death decisions, every single one of them. You cannot afford to get them wrong. And what CLP does is it forces you to make incorrect decisions. And you have to take that seriously.
这是每一个决定都关乎生死的决定。你承担不起犯错的代价。而CLP所做的就是强迫你做出错误的决定。你必须认真对待这一点。
The latest numbers from the government tell us that only 16% of asylum seekers who were caught crossing the border were able to prove they qualified for one of the CLP exceptions or rebuttals, which means 84% were not able to prove it. They could be deported.
政府的最新数据显示，只有16%被抓获越境的庇护寻求者能够证明他们符合CLP例外或反驳条件，这意味着84%的人无法证明。他们可能会被驱逐出境。
Many USCIS workers complained to leadership about this from the start. That's why they hated CLP. The response, according to George?
许多美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）工作人员从一开始就向领导层抱怨这一点。这就是他们讨厌CLP的原因。据乔治说，回应是什么？
Oh, I know some of you may disagree with this rule, and it may make you feel uncomfortable, blah, blah, blah, and this is the job. And then, they'll say, you can always quit. But they really don't care.
哦，我知道你们有些人可能不同意这个规则，它可能让你们感到不舒服，等等等等，这就是工作。然后，他们会说，你们随时可以辞职。但他们真的不在乎。
They really-- they're really channeling their inner Martin Lawrence, saying, don't let the doorknob hit you where the dog should have bit you. At the end of the day, like, they're not interested in your moral or legal objections. Shut the fuck up, put your head down, and do what you're told.
他们真的——他们真的在引导他们内心的马丁·劳伦斯（Martin Lawrence），说，别让门把手打到你应该被狗咬的地方。归根结底，他们对你们的道德或法律异议不感兴趣。闭上你的臭嘴，低下头，做被告知的事情。
I think if the administration were telling the story of CLP, they wouldn't start with the new restrictions on asylum at the border. They'd probably emphasize a different part of the rule. It's a whole new way they're enticing people to cross at the official border stations in an orderly way, instead of something more dangerous like wading across a river or walking through the desert.
我认为如果政府要讲述CLP的故事，他们不会从边境对庇护的新限制开始。他们可能会强调规则的另一部分。这是他们吸引人们以有序方式在官方边境站越境的一种全新方式，而不是像涉水过河或走过沙漠那样危险的事情。
It's an app. Yes, they have an app. It's called CBP1, and the government has big hopes for it. When the Biden administration rolled out CLP, they announced that this app was the way everyone on the southern border should apply for asylum.
这是一个应用程序。是的，他们有一个应用程序。它叫CBP1，政府对它寄予厚望。当拜登政府推出CLP时，他们宣布这个应用程序是南部边境每个人应该申请庇护的方式。
This was going to be the new system. You can get an appointment to enter the US, and it assigns you a port of entry to show up to at a specific time. Like, come to Matamoros on October 30 at 6:00 PM.
这将是新系统。你可以预约进入美国，它会指定一个入境口岸让你在特定时间出现。比如，在10月30日下午6点到马塔莫罗斯（Matamoros）。
And as an incentive to encourage you to use the app, if you download it and use it and you come in and ask for asylum, all the other CLP rules that keep people out-- they don't apply to you. Like, it doesn't matter whether you ask for asylum in other countries before you got here. You don't need to be in a medical emergency or have someone chasing you, threatening your life. It's like a golden ticket. Use the app. Apply for asylum. Period.
作为鼓励你使用该应用程序的激励措施，如果你下载并使用它，并且你进来请求庇护，所有其他让人们无法进入的CLP规则——它们都不适用于你。就像，在你到达这里之前是否在其他国家申请庇护并不重要。你不需要处于医疗紧急状态或有某人追赶你、威胁你的生命。这就像一张金票。使用应用程序。申请庇护。句号。
And I know how bonkers this sounds. On the one hand, President Biden created this weird Trumpy policy that makes it practically impossible to even ask for asylum in some ways. But on the other hand, you can sidestep all of that and just come into the United States if you have a phone and can download an app.
我知道这听起来有多疯狂。一方面，拜登总统制定了这个奇怪的特朗普式政策，在某些方面使得申请庇护几乎变得不可能。但另一方面，如果你有一部手机并且可以下载一个应用程序，你可以绕过所有这些并直接进入美国。
This has been described as a carrot-and-stick approach. They want to reward people for using the CBP1 app and coming in through official ports of entry, and they want to penalize everyone else. And having an app does seem smart. Migrants all have phones. They use apps all the time.
这被描述为胡萝卜加大棒的方法。他们想奖励使用CBP1应用程序并通过官方入境口岸进入的人，他们想惩罚其他人。而且有一个应用程序看起来确实很聪明。移民都有手机。他们一直在使用应用程序。
But I'm sure this next part will not surprise you. The app didn't work so well. From the very start of CLP this past May, it went off the rails.
但我确信这下一部分不会让你感到惊讶。这个应用程序运行得不太好。从过去5月CLP开始时，它就偏离了轨道。
First of all, there were not a lot of appointments available-- about 750 a day for the whole border. So migrants would wait for the appointments to open up, try to get one, and the app would crash. There were error messages that people didn't understand that prevented people from making appointments, like one that just said, "fraud," that continues to this day.
首先，没有多少预约名额——整个边境每天大约750个。所以移民会等待预约开放，试图得到一个，然后应用程序就会崩溃。有人们不理解的错误消息阻止人们进行预约，比如一个只写着“欺诈”的消息，这种情况一直持续到今天。
One review of the app just reads, "This app is crap," though half the reviews seem to be right-wing trolls posting things like "open-door policy, thanks, Brandon," or "come on in, front-row VIP seats for all the drug-smuggling, human-trafficking criminals that need a new stomping ground."
对该应用程序的一条评论只是写道，“这个应用程序是垃圾”，尽管一半的评论似乎是右翼喷子在发布像“开放政策，谢谢，布兰登”这样的东西，或者“欢迎进来，为所有需要新踏脚地的贩毒、人口贩运罪犯提供前排VIP席位。”
When the app did work, there were the wait times. A woman who works at a shelter in Reynosa told me she talked to a family that had been waiting for four months for their appointment. Same with Matamoros and Tijuana.
当应用程序确实有效时，有等待时间。一位在雷诺萨（Reynosa）避难所工作的一位女士告诉我，她与一个已经等待预约四个月的家庭交谈过。马塔莫罗斯和蒂华纳（Tijuana）也是一样。
The problem with waiting, besides that it sucks to wait, is that the cartels are at the border, looking to rob and kidnap asylum seekers who are stuck there. So many people just make a run for it without their golden ticket. They cross the border anywhere they can. Mark laid out for me a pretty typical case that he says he gets often.
等待的问题，除了等待本身很糟糕之外，是卡特尔在边境，寻找抢劫和绑架滞留在那里的庇护寻求者。所以许多人没有他们的金票就直接跑了。他们尽可能在任何地方越境。马克为我列出了一个他说的他经常遇到的相当典型的情况。
For example, you're hanging out in Mexico. You're planning on getting your CBP1 appointment, but they get snapped up every day, so you're waiting around. And then, in the month that you're waiting in Matamoros or wherever else, you get kidnapped, held for ransom.
例如，你在墨西哥闲逛。你计划预约CBP1，但它们每天都被抢光，所以你在等待。然后，在你等待马塔莫罗斯或其他任何地方的那个月里，你被绑架，被勒索赎金。
They make calls to your family members, using your cell phone, asking for however much money. Otherwise, they're going to kill you. Your family scrounges up whatever they can get to pay them. They pay them.
他们用你的手机给你的家人打电话，索要多少钱。否则，他们就会杀了你。你的家人拼凑他们能得到的任何钱来支付给他们。他们付钱。
You get released. You get dumped off on the side of the road somewhere. And you now have no money, because they've robbed you. They've taken all your travel documents. They've taken everything that you had with you.
你被释放了。你被扔在路边。现在你没钱了，因为他们抢劫了你。他们拿走了你所有的旅行证件。他们拿走了你随身携带的一切。
So how are you going to support yourself in this border town while you wait to get a CBP1 appointment on the phone that you no longer have? So you decide, I can't do this anymore. I got to cross into the United States.
那么，当你在这边境小镇等待在早已没有的手机上获得CBP1预约时，你将如何养活自己？所以你决定，我不能再这样了。我必须进入美国。
Mark asked me, did I think that migrant was in extreme danger, enough to get a rebuttal to the CLP rules and be allowed to apply for asylum?
马克问我，我是否认为那个移民处于极度危险之中，足以获得对CLP规则的反驳并被允许申请庇护？
It sounds like it, yeah.
听起来是的。
Well, yeah, that's not how it works. That person is not eligible for that rebuttal, because you have to demonstrate that your life or safety was in imminent danger at that exact moment when you cross into the United States. So unless that cartel or whoever kidnapped you is nipping on your heels as you dive into the water, you are not eligible for that rebuttal.
好吧，是的，这不是它的工作方式。那个人没有资格获得反驳，因为你必须证明当你进入美国的那一刻，你的生命或安全处于迫在眉睫的危险中。所以，除非那个卡特尔或绑架你的人在你潜入水里时紧跟在你的脚后，否则你没有资格获得反驳。
This is a USCIS worker I will call Joanna. She's been doing this job for a while.
这是一位我称之为乔安娜（Joanna）的美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）工作人员。她做这份工作已经有一段时间了。
It's sort of like this whole, completely nonsensical idea that you have to be actually running through the desert and trying to wage your way across the Rio Grande while bullets are flying over your head. Right? I mean, it's just-- I feel like these laws and ideas are written by people who have watched way too many World War II movies.
这有点像这种完全荒谬的想法，你必须真的跑过沙漠并试图在你穿过格兰德河（Rio Grande）时子弹在你头顶飞过。对吧？我的意思是，它只是——我觉得这些法律和想法是由看过太多二战电影的人写的。
[LAUGHS] Or, like, too many episodes of Narcos or something.
（笑）或者，就像，太多集的《毒枭》（Narcos）什么的。
Yeah, yeah, too many episodes of Narcos or, like-- I don't know. But, like, that's not-- that's not how it works.
是的，是的，太多集的《毒枭》，或者，就像——我不知道。但是，就像，那不是——那不是它的工作方式。
Stepping back and looking at the big picture, most of the people entering from our southern border are not using the CBP1 app. In October, it was about 188,000 people who got caught between ports of entry, versus about 44,000 who used the app, which means most people face the restrictive rules that make it so hard to ask for asylum.
退后一步看全局，大多数从我们南部边境进入的人并没有使用CBP1应用程序。在10月，大约有18.8万人被抓获在入境口岸之间越境，而大约有4.4万人使用了该应用程序，这意味着大多数人面临着使请求庇护变得如此困难的限制性规则。
The USCIS officials we spoke to said, under President Biden, the way CLP is written, it sounds like there are all these ways you can still apply for asylum. But in practice, it's just as bad as it was under President Trump. Because CLP denies so many people the chance at asylum at all. I asked Assistant Secretary Nunez-Neto if President Biden's policy is just as restrictive as President Trump's.
我们交谈过的美国公民及移民服务局（USCIS）官员说，在拜登总统领导下，按照CLP的编写方式，听起来好像你仍然可以通过各种方式申请庇护。但在实践中，它和特朗普总统领导下一样糟糕。因为CLP剥夺了太多人获得庇护的机会。我问助理部长努涅斯-内托，拜登总统的政策是否和特朗普总统的一样具有限制性。
Well, we are doing is a completely different and balanced approach to this issue that, again, includes an unprecedented expansion in lawful pathways and processes for people to come to the country while, at the same time, putting some common-sense constraints on the ability to claim asylum at the border for individuals at the land border between ports of entry who don't have a compelling reason why they needed to cross unlawfully between our ports of entry.
好吧，我们正在做的是针对这个问题采取一种完全不同且平衡的方法，这再次包括在合法途径和流程方面前所未有的扩大，供人们来这个国家，同时，在入境口岸之间越境且没有令人信服的理由必须这样做的个人，在陆地边境申请庇护的能力上增加了一些常识性的约束。
But in practice, what we're hearing on the ground is that people who-- that it's incredibly hard to prove the exceptions and rebuttals, that people that try to prove an exception or rebuttal that has to do with medical emergencies, for example, have died waiting for such an exception or a rebuttal. And doesn't it, in effect, at the end-- doesn't it disqualify a lot of people from even asking for asylum?
但在实践中，我们在实地听到的是，人们认为证明例外和反驳极其困难，比如尝试证明医疗紧急情况相关的例外或反驳的人在等待这种例外或反驳时已经死亡。而且，最终，它难道不是实际上取消了许多人请求庇护的资格吗？
Hey, just really quick-- I'm so sorry. I need to interrupt. Are we still on the record here?
嘿，只是非常快地——我很抱歉。我需要打断一下。我们这里还在录音吗？
At that point, Assistant Secretary Nunez-Neto's press person interrupted us. They'd agreed to answer only one question about CLP on the record. I saw this as a normal followup to clarify. They disagreed. They said they were limited on what they could say because of ongoing lawsuits about the rule.
在那一点上，助理部长努涅斯-内托的新闻发言人打断了我们。他们曾同意在录音中只回答一个关于CLP的问题。我把这视为澄清的正常后续行动。他们不同意。他们说由于关于该规则的持续诉讼，他们对能说的话有限制。
The key phrase in what he said was "a balanced approach." Administration officials I've talked to say that this mish-mash of new rules and exceptions to those rules and everything else I've described-- they say, when you put it all together, you'll see them trying to balance the humanitarian principles they say they hold dear, with the fact that they need to weed out dubious asylum claims.
他在说的话中的关键词是“平衡的方法”。我交谈过的政府官员说，这种新规则和这些规则的例外以及我描述的其他一切的混合体——他们说，当你把这一切放在一起时，你会看到他们试图在他们自称珍视的人道主义原则与他们需要剔除可疑庇护申请的事实之间取得平衡。
I think what's happening is, there's a humanitarian crisis, so many people arriving at the border, and a backlog of nearly 3 million immigration cases already, that the administration had to figure out something to do with the tens of thousands of people showing up each week. And they're scared of looking soft on immigration, but they also don't want to be anti-immigrant.
我认为正在发生的是，存在一场人道主义危机，有这么多人到达边境，以及已经积压了近300万起移民案件，政府不得不设法处理每周出现的人数以万计的人。而且他们害怕看起来对移民软弱，但他们也不想反移民。
They don't think of themselves as anti-immigrant. So they ended up with this contradictory hodgepodge, letting in over a million people for humanitarian reasons, but that's just temporary relocation, or setting up CLP rules that are both deeply restrictive and surprisingly unrestrictive. Of course it's a mess.
他们不认为自己是反移民的。所以他们最终得到了这种矛盾的混杂物，出于人道主义理由让一百多万人进来，但这只是临时搬迁，或者是设定既深度限制又令人惊讶地不限制的CLP规则。当然这是一团糟。
CLP is currently being challenged in court in two separate federal cases. The ACLU is suing the Biden administration in both, saying that CLP makes it too hard for people to apply for asylum, in violation of the law. The Asylum Officers' Union has filed two amicus briefs, one for each of the lawsuits, saying they agree. They represent about 1,000 asylum officers. Assistant Secretary Nunez-Neto told me the administration is confident the rule is legal.
CLP目前在两个独立的联邦案件中受到法律挑战。美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）在两者中都在起诉拜登政府，称CLP使得人们太难申请庇护，违反了法律。庇护官工会已经提交了两份法庭之友陈述书，每起诉讼一份，称他们同意。他们代表了大约1000名庇护官。助理部长努涅斯-内托告诉我，政府有信心该规则是合法的。
There's one phrase that one of the officers, Joanna, used that stuck with me. She said, "the Overton window has shifted," which means the window of political acceptability has changed. The goalposts have moved, because of Trump's strategy on asylum, where the goal, according to Joanna, was to kill the asylum program. Allow no one in. Give no protection. And when the Biden administration created CLP, Joanna thinks they co-signed on the idea of, let's just not anymore, just with a different tone.
乔安娜（Joanna）使用的一句话让我印象深刻。她说，“奥弗顿窗口（Overton window）已经转移了”，这意味着政治可接受性的窗口已经改变了。目标已经移动，因为特朗普在庇护上的策略，根据乔安娜的说法，其目标是杀死庇护计划。不允许任何人进来。不提供任何保护。而当拜登政府创造CLP时，乔安娜认为他们签署了这样的想法，即，让我们不再那样做，只是换个语调。
Like, if you look at it, now that you have seen the Biden administration in action in asylum, what things are you like, yes, this is-- they actually have made some changes, here's where it's different, and here is where it's the same as how it was under Trump?
就像，如果你看看它，现在你已经看到了拜登政府在庇护方面的行动，哪些事情让你觉得，是的，这是——他们确实做了一些改变，这里有什么不同，哪里和特朗普时期一样？
OK, well, they don't pull babies away from mothers' arms. So I guess you get a sticker or a cookie. Yay for you. They talk about it differently. Yeah, that's really important.
好吧，好吧，他们不会把婴儿从母亲的怀里拉走。所以我想你会得到一个贴纸或饼干。为你欢呼。他们谈论它的方式不同。是的，那非常重要。
Democrats don't call countries "shithole countries." They just-- they treat them like shithole countries. But I think with the Biden administration, you have a pretense at protection that the Trump people didn't do. There's something just like, ugh, right?
民主党人不把国家称为“屎坑国家”。他们只是——他们像对待屎坑国家一样对待它们。但我认为在拜登政府下，你有一种特朗普政府没有做的虚假保护。有一些就像，呃，对吧？
Do you think it's worse than it was under Trump?
你认为它比特朗普时期更糟糕吗？
I mean, it's very bad and very similar. But it's a different kind.
我的意思是，它非常糟糕且非常相似。但它是一种不同的类型。
What do you mean a different kind?
你指的是哪种不同？
So do you know what's-- what is worse? Someone who's direct in doing something bad or someone who dresses up a little nicer and puts a better face on it but still does pretty much the same thing? I think we'll look back on the first two years of the Biden administration and the future and identify this as an inflection point when we just kind of, like, stop the pretense of having an asylum system that comports with our legal obligations under international and federal law.
所以你知道什么是——什么是更糟糕的？是直接做坏事的人，还是打扮得漂亮一点，换上一副更好的面孔，但仍然做同样事情的人？我认为我们将回顾拜登政府的前两年和未来，并将此视为一个转折点，当时我们只是，就像，停止了假装拥有一个符合我们国际和联邦法律义务的庇护系统。
Maybe that's the real bipartisan agreement at this point. This system that we built to function as our own idealistic cavalry to protect people who are fleeing for their lives-- both parties seem to have decided that we don't need to do that anymore. Instead of looking at why you're coming to the US and judging that on its merits, now, we'll block you because of how you came to the US, whether you use the CBP1 app, whether you ask for asylum from countries along the way. If you're the most vulnerable, the most in need of rescuing, our asylum system, as it stands, may no longer save you.
也许这就是目前真正的两党共识。我们构建这个旨在作为我们自己理想主义骑兵来保护那些为生命奔逃的人们的系统——两党似乎已经决定我们不再需要这样做。与其看你为什么来到美国并根据其优点做出判断，现在，我们会因为你如何来到美国而阻挡你，无论是使用CBP1应用程序，还是在沿途国家请求庇护。如果你是最脆弱的，最需要救援的，我们的庇护系统，就目前而言，可能不再能拯救你了。
Nadia Reiman is an editor on our program. Julia Preston helped us out as a consulting editor on this story.
纳迪亚·雷曼是我们节目的编辑。朱莉娅·普雷斯顿（Julia Preston）作为顾问编辑帮助我们完成了这个故事。
Our program was produced today by Miki Meek. The people who put together today's show include James Bennett the Second, Phia Bennin, Susan Burton, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Andrea López Cruzado, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Alissa Shipp, Alix Spiegel, Laura Starecheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目是由米基·米克（Miki Meek）制作的。制作今天节目的成员包括詹姆斯·贝内特二世（James Bennett the Second）、菲亚·贝宁（Phia Bennin）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、安德里亚·洛佩兹·克鲁扎多（Andrea López Cruzado）、卡西·豪利（Cassie Howley）、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯（Valerie Kipnis）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、斯托·纳尔逊（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基（Laura Starecheski）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、玛丽莎·罗伯逊-泰克斯托（Marisa Robertson-Textor）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Voice actors for our asylum story in act two-- Evan Jonigkeit, Jake Lacy, Hannah Gross, and Abby Elliot. Special thanks today to Alaa Mostafa, Sabrina Hyman, Michael Knowles from the USCIS Employees Union, the Migration Policy Institute, Aaron Reichlin-Melnick, Hollie Webb, Kassandra Gonzalez, Dana Leigh Marks, Erin Heeter, Michael Mascari, Kathryn Mattingly, and Lee Gelernt.
我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。第二幕我们庇护故事的配音演员——埃文·乔尼凯特（Evan Jonigkeit）、杰克·莱西（Jake Lacy）、汉娜·格罗斯（Hannah Gross）和艾比·埃利奥特（Abby Elliot）。今天特别感谢阿拉·穆斯塔法（Alaa Mostafa）、萨布丽娜·海曼（Sabrina Hyman）、来自USCIS员工工会的迈克尔·诺尔斯（Michael Knowles）、移民政策研究所（Migration Policy Institute）、亚伦·赖希林-梅尔尼克（Aaron Reichlin-Melnick）、霍莉·韦伯（Hollie Webb）、卡桑德拉·冈萨雷斯（Kassandra Gonzalez）、达纳·利·马克斯（Dana Leigh Marks）、艾琳·希特（Erin Heeter）、迈克尔·马斯卡里（Michael Mascari）、凯瑟琳·马廷利（Kathryn Mattingly）和李·格伦特（Lee Gelernt）。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there is merch for the podcast-slash-public-radio-loving nerds in your life and your holiday shopping needs. Again-- thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费流媒体播放我们超过800集的档案。此外，还有为你生活中喜爱播客和公共广播的极客准备的周边商品，满足你的节日购物需求。再次——thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our show's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, some woman was flirting with him in a bar last weekend. She asked if he wanted to go home with her. He gave her a blank stare. She asked if he had protection. He said, of course.
《美国生活》由公共广播交易所（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，上周末有个女人在酒吧和他调情。她问他想不想和她一起回家。他给了她一个空白的凝视。她问他是否有保护措施。他说，当然。
I always have two doses of anti-venom on hand.
我手头总是有两剂抗蛇毒素。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多美国生活故事回来。